[Music]
Antarctica a continent so far from any
other landmass beyond the wild southern
ocean that for a long time we didn't
even know it existed it was only two
hundred years ago that humans finally
laid eyes on it
and it was on small wooden ships like
this when they sailed around Cape Horn
they fail sailed further and further
south note he's been down there all the
were was on the charts was ice that was
that was it so he went actually off the
charts first came the whalers and
sealers then the explorers like Scott
and Shackleton and Nations started to
claim territory in the Second World War
the British government launched a
top-secret expedition to defend its
territorial claims to the Antarctic
Peninsula and beyond Port Lockroy was
one of their bases and it still stands
today a reminder that even here the only
continent that has never seen a war
geopolitics still matter by the 1950s
seven countries had claimed territories
in Antarctica some of which overlapped
it was a mess the Antarctic Treaty
sought to overcome it ignored the land
grabs and put peace and science first
now there are 30 countries with 82
research stations on the continent but
the science is also strategic the UK
isn't alone in sending the military to
help with the logistics this Hercules
flying over Britain's main research base
had dropped supplies to remote field
camps by parachute science has always
been a proxy for geopolitics nothing's
changed so countries for example went to
great lengths to put their Antarctic
stations all over Antarctica and to
raise national flags to say we're here
we're busy this is ours climate change
is going to continue to place pressures
on the Antarctic it also means that
countries like China are
become increasingly dominant in
demanding a voice about how Antarctica
is governed after all cities like
Shanghai will bear the brunt of
sea-level rise but Antarctica faces new
challenges in the 21st century
tourism is set to double pressure on
fish stocks is increasing and there's
always the risk of conflict spreading
south the Foreign Office says science is
crucial to keeping the peace the reason
we study it so hard is because the water
that is going to melt from Antarctica
will arrive around the coast of the UK
we're not complacent till naive the
treaty is the best thing ever but the
evidence shows that most states feel
that they're better off cooperating
within the treaty to understand
Antarctica and have a say in how its
governed than trying to go alone in the
200 years since we've discovered
Antarctica humans have altered its
climate perhaps irreversibly the treaty
protecting it has never been so tested
and never been so critical Thomas More
Sky News on the Antarctic Peninsula